hello everybody welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and on the podcast we've talked about
democracy quite a bit in different
contexts
we're going to keep talking about it i
think it's a very important as well as
fascinating topic
but usually when you think about
democracy when you have a discussion
about it
there's different angles you can take
you can talk about it from a political
point of view obviously
historical point of view as we've done
philosophical point of view
the justifications for democracy are
generally that
it's the right thing to do right it
gives voice to the people who are in a
country
but what about the question of is
democracy any good
at achieving whatever goals the people
in the country actually have
so this is almost a scientific point of
view of democracy or at least sort of
instrumental computational point of view
is democracy good at
problem solving that's the question
being asked by today's guest henry
farrell now henry is a
well-known political theorist he writes
a lot about not just democracy but
international relations and so forth
but with his collaborator cosmo chilizi
he's been thinking about
democracy as a problem-solving mechanism
the cognitive aspects
of democracy and basically what you can
do is think about democracy
as one kind of emergence right
when we talk about countries we often
anthropomorphize them we say this
country has these desires or these goals
or something like that
a little bit sketchy because a country
is not a person right
but in some sense countries act as if
they are
agents that emerge out of all the people
that make them up and there's different
ways
that the viewpoint of a country can be
instantiated
given what its people want you could
have an autocracy where there's
basically the people
have some way of giving all the power to
one person over some very small number
of people
you could have markets in some sense
right so you have different sets of
people who are bidding against each
other
and of course you can have democracy
where in some sense everyone is voting
expressing a preference and then you
sort of either take a majority or you
have some mechanism
for turning those individual votes into
preferences for the wider
country and so what henry's going to
argue is that democracy is actually
really good
at solving problems sort of surprisingly
good in some sense not perfect
but these other mechanisms can get stuck
right these other mechanisms of
taking the views of many many people and
converting them into a single action
can get stuck in ruts can miss obvious
solutions because they're not as
creative as a democracy can be
and like many mindscape discussions even
though henry's political theorist
he takes a scientific point of view on
this so we have analogies
to not only physics but also
evolutionary biology
and things like that so it's an
interesting angle on an old question you
know democracy how it works
let's be sciency about it let's think
about how this actually happens in the
real world so
let's go
henry farrell welcome to the mindscape
podcast wonderful to be here talking to
you
so let me start by asking a question so
that i can better understand
the landscape of political science
government academia which i don't know
that much about i mean it seems
reading your stuff uh obviously you're
you're perfectly
respectable political scientist you
write about international relations and
institutions and things like that but it
seems to me that you are more
sympathetic than the average political
scientist to thinking about these
institutions
like a physicist would think about them
or like a scientist would think about
them you know as
dynamic complex systems interacting in
different ways with equations in the
whole bit
is that is that an accurate gauge or is
there like a whole
discourse going on out there that i just
don't know about no that is that is
right there
isn't nearly as much discussion of this
stuff in political science as you might
expect
uh so we are seeing people who are
beginning to start to use uh machine
learning techniques of one sort or
another random farce and similar types
of things for
extracting meaning from data but in
terms of actually thinking about
political processes in these ways which
is something that i think is really
important
we really don't have nearly as much as
we ought to have there is one
wonderful semi-forgotten political
scientist from the 1960s charles
lindbloom
he thought a lot about the world in
these kinds of ways and of course
political scientists are aware of the
work of herbert simon
even if they tend to focus not on the
areas of simon's work that really talks
these questions and much more
on his ideas about satisficing more
generally but we don't have that kind of
a conversation that is really yet
to get going and i think the reason why
i'm interested in this is because of an
experience we both share
of having been around in the dawn ages
of the blogosphere when
there were so few people actually
writing and thinking as academics about
this stuff that you begin to
have these different social networks and
i think it was through talking to people
like you
talking to people like cosmos lizzie who
has become a
regular partner in crime at carnegie
mellon
that i started to get interested in
these questions and then getting exposed
to
a lot of people in santa fe and other
places that are also thinking about the
world in these kinds of ways
that's excellent i mean when people ask
me uh did the blogosphere
in its heyday ever lead to anything good
my best example is that
uh i found my wife through the
blogosphere since jennifer and i
are both bloggers but you have a much
more academic uh intellectual
reason to to give it credit which is
good
um and i also found my job uh i my
spouse
was living in dc at the time and it was
very enthusiastic for me to get a job in
dc
and then one day i got an email from
somebody who later became a colleague of
mine
inquiring gingerly i was at university
of toronto whether i wanted
to apply for a job that they had going
and uh i jumped on that and my spouse
promised she would never complain about
me blocking again and she
she's mostly managed to keep that
promise over the intervening decades
you know this probably has lessons for
the spread of information over networks
and diverse opinions and things like
that which will get too good so you know
even though we're chit-chatting now it
actually does have to do with the
substance
of the conversation so let's start with
uh this idea of
democracy and and other kinds of
institutions
in a more or less theoretical sense you
know the the
probably the thing that is going to
guide this conversation the most is the
paper that he wrote with cosmos elizi on
cognitive
democracy and i i take it that the idea
is to think about democracy
as a way of making decisions and to
compare with other institutional ways of
making decisions is that fair
that's right so we can think about
markets we can think about democracy we
can think about hierarchy
we can think about all of these as
different modes of problem solving and
what i mean by problem solving here is
something like the following so imagine
that there are a number of us and we
have some shared problem
in common that we would like to solve
but either
a it is a complex problem that is that
the solution is not immediately and
readily apparent
or b we have strong disagreements about
how to solve it i think that is where
uh where where we can start to begin to
get some traction
on which modes of uh governance whether
these this be markets whether this be
democracy whether this be hierarchy
are better or worse at solving
individual problems and so i think that
the argument that cosmo and i have made
there and i think we would probably
modify it some i think we're a little
bit too enthusiastic about democracy
as against its competitors in that piece
but i think that the argument that we
make is that the
ability of democracy to solve problems
is underestimated
because people don't pay attention to
the ways in which democracy
forces people ideally with very
different perspectives very different
wants
to work together and sometimes from the
very diversity of our goals and our
wants information emerges and the
democratic process works best when it is
actually able to harness that process
and turn that information into something
useful and something actionable
to help us solve problems and so just to
put the audience in the right mindset
here when we think about democracy
most of us are going to be thinking
about the government right you know the
society in which we live in it's it's a
it's a system of governance
but we can think about it more
abstractly i mean i i take it that
your view of democracy works uh when it
comes to governments but also just
other decision-making processes more
broadly
i think that's right and this is work
that i've been doing more recently
together with two colleagues of mine
hugo mercier whose work
is mentioned in the cognitive democracy
piece
i'm melissa schwartzberg who is a
wonderful political theorist at
new york university and part of what
we've been trying to do is come up with
this
research program that we call no
[ __ ] democracy and the idea behind
it
is as follows that there is a lot of
language being used by democracy or
democracy is awesome according to its
defenders democracy is terrible
according to a variety of very
influential libertarian critics
popped up over the last decade or 15
years and what we want to do is to try
and
change the conversation a little bit to
say that there are all of these
different forms of democracy these
different forms in which democratic
decision making can happen
some of them work well some of them work
terribly let's start to try and figure
out a more scientific way
of understanding how to do this and
because hugo is a cognitive psychologist
and because we are really working from
that micro level
a lot of the argument we make in the no
[ __ ] democracy paper
is really saying we need to build up
from these insights that cognitive
psychologists have developed about when
group
problem solving works and when it
doesn't to start trying to figure out
what are the parameters under which
democracy will work well or badly
but equally one could imagine a very
similar research program
and a complimentary research program
working downwards from some of the work
that statistical physicists and others
have been doing on contagion over large
scale networks and trying to use that as
ways of modeling
how these much bigger social processes
which are not small groups but in fact
are taking place at a much higher level
of social articulation
how those can have both good and bad uh
facets too
and again to try and put this kind of
insight into
a feedback loop between on the one hand
exploration of the theoretical
possibilities and on the other hand
trying to figure out what works
practically and what doesn't because of
course
uh you can theorize all you want uh but
they're going to be major facets of
actual real-life democratic politics
that you aren't going to get
until you see what works in practice
what doesn't
and this is the kind of debate that at
least i think hugo and melissa and i
would like to see uh happening
and of course cosmo and i as you say
have uh talked about this in a slightly
different space uh earlier
and uh there is a lot of work that needs
to be done yeah it's very much in line
with the
spherical cow philosophy that physicists
have right like let's let's do the
simple thing first
then we can add in the complications
later and hopefully that doesn't change
everything about the problem that we're
working on
uh but you said before we get back to
that train of thought you said one
little provocative thing about
there are libertarian critiques of
democracy and maybe you should share
with us
what those are because i think that at
the very naive level we might think of
libertarians as being maximally
democratic but are they worried that you
know the majority rule is going to
interfere with their rights is that the
basic
worry so i think that that that probably
is their basic worry but they proceed
from a different direction so here i'm
thinking about three books which have
gotten
public attention over the last 10 or 15
years one by jason brennan called
against democracy
which is a little bit of a if he's a
business school professor
and a uh trained as a philosopher at
georgetown and it's a bit bit of a shock
jock book he is very clearly trying to
uh be
maximally annoying to the people whose
opinions he dislikes
and there are also books by brian kaplan
who i think is doing this from a less
a less provocative uh but nonetheless
extremely strongly
worded perspective and ilya soman who is
a george mason university
law professor all of these are arguing
more or less that democracy
is doomed to failure and democracy is
doomed to failure
for two reasons first of all because
individual citizens are ignorant that is
that they do not have the kinds of
political knowledge
they would need to take to have in order
to take good decisions
and secondly that they are hopelessly
cognitively biased
that my side bias and a variety of other
biases mean that they simply aren't able
to think straight about politics
and so we have these uh these authors
proposing
different alternatives to democracy so
brennan proposes what he calls
epistocracy which is a kind of an
aristocracy of those who know better and
he has different flavors of this
some involving a pretty strong rule of
an elite
others involving elites having greater
voting weight or whatever
and we have kaplan arguing that we need
to rely much more on markets
and someone saying both markets and the
possibility of exit that is the
possibility if you don't like a
political arrangement
to be easily able to leave it and go for
another as being different
alternatives to democracy uh someone
says that we should uh
we should limit democracy and the two
others i think are looking for
much more radical uh pushback against
democracy so these are the people who
are
in a sense disagreeing with this
perspective and disagreeing from a point
of view which says that
democracy as a problem-solving system is
doomed because
effectively uh the citizens don't have
the knowledge
or the capability to judge that they
would need to have
in order for democracy to work well i
mean that that point of view has
seeped into the practical discourse a
little bit just over the past couple
weeks
i've seen uh claims
in the space of uh voting rights you
know
certain let's say one political party in
our current system is trying to expand
voting rights and another one is trying
to shrink it a little bit and there's
been little tentative
efforts to say well we
we're we shouldn't count votes equally
among people who are equally
uh educated or equally informed right i
mean this is
not how our democracy actually works
right now but i've at least seen
some people on one side of the ledger
bring up that argument i don't know if
it's directly related to the academic
discussion you're talking about
uh certainly there are linkages and
connections it's very very hard to say
that somebody is saying this because
they've read this that and the other
and of course there is a very very long
history
in u.s politics of voting restrictions
that are nominally supposed to be based
upon
knowledge of one sort or another so that
when you look at the pre-civil rights
south
iu very often had tests being
administered to voters which were very
deliberately
specifically intended to exclude
african-american voters and to make sure
that they had no chance of
having a say so there there is this long
lasting independent
tradition of looking for spurious
justifications from stopping people from
voting if you
are worried that they are going to vote
in ways that you don't want them to vote
and this very often tends to be on the
conservative side of the political
spectrum because
if you're a conservative you're somebody
who believes in property
and uh one of the great worries of the
conservative movement as daniel ziblat
and others have discussed daniel ziblat
is a very very interesting political
scientist is that uh conservatives have
always worried that as the franchise
expands
uh people will use the franchise to vote
the rich
out of their property and so equally if
you are a rich person you are
in the market perhaps for ideological
justifications for why it is that we
ought to restrict the franchise so
there has always been that tradition
there but i think that what these people
do
in particular brennan's book i think has
lent a patent of respectability to these
arguments
and really has given a sense that there
is some
intellectual weight behind them i
frankly think that this is an extremely
bad book in a variety of ways i think
it's poorly argued
uh it hopelessly misre represents much
of the cognitive science literature that
it uh purports to draw upon and of
course this is a topic that hugo
melissa and i are interested in talking
more about
very good yeah it's good you know
sometimes bad books can lead to
good things if their response to them is
productive not not always true but
okay look it's very clear that we could
have a six hour long conversation
because i'm fascinated by all the stuff
that you're saying but let's retrench a
little bit and get back to this question
of
using democracy as a decision-making
tool i mean
before we get into comparing democracy
with markets and hierarchies and things
let me think about what that means i
i mean democracy is both a way to not
just make a decision but also to
decide what it is we value right i mean
uh typically a decision making process
if i'm if i'm a computer scientist and
writing an algorithm
i know what my uh fitness function is
or whatever that i want to maximize and
i just figure out a way to do it
but democracy kind of mixes that up
right i'm deciding what i value
and deciding how to get it at the same
time so it's a little bit different
maybe there are a whole lot of
interesting differences there and i
think there's a very interesting i was
listening to a podcast a couple of weeks
ago
uh this was the quanta podcast with
steven strogatz
and he was interviewing moon duchenne
who is a
mathematician at tufts and she said and
i think this is absolutely right that
democracy
is not an optimization problem and this
is i think a temptation that a lot of
people with engineering
our mathematical backgrounds have is to
think in a certain sense well
why is it that people disagree if we
could just come up with some sweet
engineering solution everybody would
realize that we would find some kind of
optimal
uh optimal solution there are real
number of reasons why this is not true
one of those is what you've already
touched upon which is that
we often figure out what our goals are
in the process of actually seeking after
them and this is an argument that
political theorists such as john dewey
have made at length so i think that the
best articulation of this is a wonderful
albeit i think also flawed book that
dewey wrote back in the 1920s called the
public and its problems
where he conceives of democracy as
effectively a means of trying to figure
out these broader problems that we have
and to but in a process of discovery
which both involves ordinary members of
the public and
experts ordinary members of the public
uh understand
how the problem affects them in their
lives and experts perhaps
understand the more subtle causal chains
that
mean that a public has a shared problem
so first of all a public identifies
itself and then the public
tries to create the means through which
it can actually
address the problem but the implication
of all of this uh and dewey is a
pragmatist
is that this is going to be an a
never-ending process of discovery
where in trying to solve the problems
the public will of course figure out
that some of its goals are appropriate
and some of its goals wildly
misconceived the nature of the problem
and so there's going to be an endless
process of revision and that is
something that
is crucial and important the other part
of this which is something that dewey i
think is bad at
is understanding how it is that people
in a democratic society
have very different goals uh we are
tossed together
in american society and i think this is
part of the
issue that we have at the moment with uh
polarization with people who have very
very different goals
very different understandings of what
the shared
situation what the shared outcome ought
to be uh what our goals ought to be what
kinds of values or to guide those goals
and so democracy then becomes a process
of
group warfare to some degree when it
works badly
or group accommodation where you work
together and you sometimes figure out
messy and painful and agonizing
solutions
which don't please ever anybody but
which nonetheless and sort of allow you
to continue on together
in relative peace while addressing some
of the problems that everybody can agree
or problems or whatever
and so this is a really messy process
but it also is not an optimization
process this is much more like a
uh if you think about it in slightly
more abstract
terms you are searching across a uh
rugged solution space where
you do not know what the solutions are
uh you know
you know that some solutions are going
to be better than others but you want to
make sure that you don't get
trapped at some local peak which is much
lower than the peaks that you might be
able to achieve
otherwise and so then you have all of
the really messy and complicated
processes of actually figuring out what
kinds of modes of decision making
might or might not be better able to
guide you to the
better local optima donating to charity
can be rewarding personally and can help
make the world a better place
but you want to know the money you're
giving is really having an impact
that's where givewell.org comes in since
2010
givewell.org has helped over 50 000
donors
find the places where their donations
can save or improve
lives the most every year they do
exhaustive research for over twenty
thousand hours
to find the highest impact
evidence-based charities
and then they give away their answers
for free givewell publishes all of their
research
on their site they do not take a cut out
of your donation
i use givewell because as nice as it is
to feel good about giving to charity
it feels even better if you have
evidence-based reasons for thinking that
your money is actually doing something
if you've never donated to givewell's
recommended charities before
you can have your donation matched up to
a thousand dollars before the end of
june or as long as matching funds last
just go to givewell.org mindscape and
pick
podcast and mindscape at checkout make
sure they know
that you heard about givewell from
mindscape to get your donation matched
that's givewell.org mindscape
select podcast and mindscape at checkout
and you know maybe it would be useful
just to back up even further because
this uh notion this metaphor because
that's what it is of a fitness landscape
is i guess borrowed from evolutionary
biology
um physicists use the landscape metaphor
but we just
reverse the sign of the function because
we think that
balls and water flow downhill and you
end up at the bottom of the fitness
landscape whereas
in evolution we think that animals like
to climb mountains for some reason so
you go to the top
of the fitness landscape but but pretend
i've never heard of what a fitness
landscape is tell me how you think about
what that uh metaphor actually does for
us
well like all metaphors can be
misleading and i think one of the
problems when you try to
apply these evolutionary metaphors
too easily to uh to political processes
is that uh you know trying to figure out
what the actual fitness function is you
know so that you're trying to achieve
and you know
this is this is in itself uh not an
obvious task this is not something is
especially given the people are likely
to have strong disagreements about the
goals that they are supposed to reach
i think it's a useful metaphor but i
think it's one that one shouldn't
push too far that said what uh
so cosma and danielle allen who is a
political theorist
at uh harvard and is also uh currently a
candidate
uh for she is running for uh
governorship of massachusetts a
political practitioner as well yeah
and as an altogether wonderful person
i've got to say i'm extremely lucky i'm
lucky in my collaborators of all of whom
are terrifyingly
far more brilliant uh than i am but uh
but
what we have tried to do there is to try
and use this evolutionary uh
you know this notion of evolutionary
fitness states to try and think
a little bit more clearly about
democracy and more or less an
undirected pro uh an undirected process
of problem solving so the idea here
is something as follows that if you
think about how and i'm here i'm
simplifying
uh radically that if you think about how
democracy works versus for example
systems such as
autocracy uh you know so you can think
about them as
drawing upon possible solutions to so to
uh problems that a society faces here
again i'm abstracting away all of these
difficult and complex problems about
do we agree what a solution is do we
even agree on what a problem is etc etc
but if you start from that kind of
metaphor then you can reasonably see
that some solutions which are likely to
pass muster
in a democratic space because they are
to the benefit of the collective
majority
are probably going to get blocked in an
autocratic
situation are in a democracy where there
are extreme power disparities
because some of these solutions even if
they uh are overall beneficial for the
society
are going to be uncongenial to the
powerful
minority the elite was in that society
and so what that suggests then
is that uh under reasonable
circumstances
we can say that democracy is likely to
have a dynamic advantage
vis-a-vis vis-a-vis authoritarian
systems
in its ability to search this landscape
for possible solutions the problems
for problems that pop up and we think
about this primarily in terms of
problems of institutional change finding
new rules because there's literatures
there that we want to talk to
and one could also say that more equal
democracies
ipso facto and holding all things equal
are probably going to be
uh better at doing this at searching for
good solutions then
less equal democracies precisely because
uh it is less likely that
elites are going to be able to block
these solutions from being adopted
in a more general way so maybe this is a
useful place to distinguish how
physicists think about this from how
biologists do because like i said a
physicist is thinking about a ball
rolling down a hill
it's one thing in a landscape and it
will find the minimum or at least a
local minimum and then sit there
but biologists have this uh well i don't
know if it's an advantage or
disadvantage but it's a difference
that you have a population right there's
a whole species with slightly different
genomes right slightly different traits
some of us are taller than others or
shorter or whatever
and constantly shuffling around in a
non-four-sided way trying different
things and so the whole population kind
of climbs up
the fitness landscape uh by trying
different things and it
if there's another peak that is not
right nearby maybe you could find it
just because evolution
is randomly trying out different things
far away and so
is that quite analogous or just a little
bit analogous to the idea that in a
democracy
you have a bunch of people with
different ideas is it people with
different ideas and opinions analogous
to
the different genomes in a population so
this is
so what we do the way in which we try to
solve this in this paper
uh and of course there are many ways in
which you could solve this
is by thinking about the population
question being what we call
institutional a population of
institutional beliefs and so here the
idea is something that like as follows
if we think about
our lives our lives are governed by a
variety of social and political
institutions you know so if you walk out
of the
door and you go you you start driving
home
uh you know it matters whether you're in
ireland or in the united states
as to whether or not you're going to
drive on the left side or the right side
of the road
and uh if you drive on the wrong side of
the road
that's going to result in problems so
this is one very simple
and one very arbitrary institution and
it's also an institution which is
largely self-enforcing because those
people who don't
who don't abide by the institution tend
to get as
selected out of a broader population of
human beings very very quickly
but we can imagine that when there are
more complicated solutions or
complicated institutions
then there's going to be a significant
degree of variation
among us in how we actually understand
those institutions so one thing that
has come to my mind over the last year
obviously is looking at a mask wearing
in my local neighborhood and uh
clearly there are informal rules about
uh you wear masks under this
circumstance you don't wear masks under
those
and there also is a perfect amount of
churn in the institution
if the institution is changing perhaps
in response to
individuals uh assessment of the
underlying risks
perhaps also in response to a purely
stochastic uh
you know sort of a chance some sort of
meaning that um
somebody's somebody makes a slightly
different decision and then there's some
sort of rebound throughout the entire
population
so then if we think about institutions
as being these populations of beliefs
you know
everybody has a slightly different
belief about what the institutional rule
is
in people's heads then uh one could also
assume that the
and this is the second thing we do that
the
the the ways in which we interpret the
world our underlying heuristics for
interpreting the world
are likely to lead to greater variation
in the beliefs that pop up
and sometimes whether or not it is
because we mistake an institution
whether or not it is because we are
trying to resist an institution
deliberately trying to subvert it
or perhaps we're just coming together
and we're talking and we figure out a
better way because our two different
ways of thinking about the world collide
in a way that allows us to discover
something new
new institute new variant beliefs can
spring up and then the question of which
beliefs
which institutional beliefs spread
across the population of human beings to
then become a new institution
you can then begin to model that
according to the uh relative power of
the elite uh versus the non-elite
by treating this as a process of network
contagion so that's
more or less the insight behind that
there obviously is a lot more
complicated mathematics
but here i am frankly and completely
free writing on my course or cosma ahu
is uh
you know i i i'm able to appreciate and
to use his insights but i am not under
any circumstances capable of replicating
those insights in a
reasonable way so well you know i've
never free ridden on any of my
colleagues
superior math skills so i have no idea
what you're talking about but let me let
me
pick out one little persnickety science
thing here which probably is not
important but but maybe it is just so
i'll check when biology when natural
selection
operates one of its key features is that
it
does have zero foresight right that that
the uh mutations in the
genome or the sexual selection or
whatever is not
trying to solve a problem and darwin's
great insight is that it nevertheless
kind of solves a problem and so we human
beings hopefully
have this extra ability to uh imagine
different possibilities to to think
about a possible solution without yet
trying it out and seeing if it works
does that change the math or the
dynamics in some important way
or is it just sort of go along for the
ride it's something that's really
difficult to incorporate in the model so
i think that
what our approach does i think it does
two things reasonably well first of all
i think it's
much better capturing informal
institutions that is these rules like
the rules over mask wearing
that arise in a kind of spontaneous way
from a broad population
than it is at capturing formal
institutions such as the question of
whether or not the filibuster
is or is not going to survive in the us
senate i think you would want you know
you would not want to start with our
kind of
framework to be coming up with useful
insights as to what is going to happen
there and the second thing that it does
is it kind of it
it shoehorns all of those forces that
you're talking about human creativity
and it more or less makes them into a
you know it
shovels them into the noise term into
the equation so these are
you know the the notion is more or less
but we're going to see more creativity
happening
when we have a population of diverse
actors uh interacting with each other to
some degree
and this is going to create more noise
which then generates new evolutionary
variations
which appear but uh very clearly
that actually cuts out a lot of what is
really important
and really interesting and really
ingenious about the ways in which human
beings
craftily manage to manipulate the
circumstances around them
in ways that you know survive to their
advantage or to the advantage of their
loved ones or whatever
so like all models you know you you it
it helps but you you you you don't want
to take it
entirely seriously as a complete picture
of the world
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to take one part of an incredibly
complex set of causal relationships and
make them
tractable so that we can better
understand this
while at the same time being aware that
they're going to be some pretty profound
limitations to the model and
you you want to make sure that you you
want to make sure that you're careful
in extrapolating too simply and too
easily from the model to the real world
well one of my long-standing miracles
again yeah one of my long-standing goals
for the podcast is uh
to inspire young graduate students that
there's plenty of problems out there and
uh
not yet solved or at least plenty of
techniques worth trying so maybe this is
something some
room for uh for building on what you've
done
but let's get okay good let's let's uh i
think we can
maybe anchor this a little bit more by
contrasting
the ability of democracy democracies to
solve problems to find the maxima
fitness landscapes
with the alternatives that you give and
so in the paper you talk about markets
and hierarchies as two alternatives and
first
that at first struck me a little bit
weird i mean i think that in the popular
imagination markets and democracies go
along together but
but you you're sort of opposing them as
different ways of decision-making which
does make sense once you read the paper
but maybe you could explain it
well here what we're doing in a sense
we're disagreeing with people like
friedrich hayek who has
a pair of very very interesting and
indeed revelatory papers
where he's talking about at the price
mechanism and how it is the price
mechanism serves as a process of
discovery and more or less the argument
is making something like the following
that
you have diffused knowledge about the
world i have diffused knowledge about
the world
and there isn't any real way for us to
be able to share this uh
in a way that helps us to solve problems
but we can rely upon the price
mechanism very often to do this you may
be an incredibly good grower of tomatoes
i may be an incredibly good maker of
tomato sauce
and the ways in which we figure out
yourself for example you know
which kinds of tomatoes to grow are what
kinds of
sources to make is by using the price
mechanism as a kind of a summary
statistic
of all of these you know complex
relationships of uh
production and hence in a sense the uh
price mechanism becomes this uh
extraordinary means of capturing signal
out of a
set of latent processes that are very
very you know that that
are fundamentally invisible to human
beings or at least inarticulable by
human beings it's very very hard to
explain without
showing or doing how it is to do to make
tomatoes so what we're trying to do is
we're trying to argue in a sense that
hayek you know it's it's a real insight
and there are incredible things that
markets can do
and also this is the point that limb
blue makes is that you don't
ever get any democracies there are no
historical examples of democracies which
have not had
markets going together with them so
there is some
plausible complex causal relationship
between the two
but that there are certain things that
markets are going to be terrible at
doing and these very often are going to
be
those uh instances where human you know
where human interaction
and where human verbal exchange and
reasoning
and giving of reasons can help us to
understand how politics works and this
is where i would turn back to uh
mercier's work and in particular
a landmark book that he's written with
dan sperber called the enigma of reason
where they argue first of all i think
it's a really interesting argument
is that first of all human reasoning
evolves not as a way of figuring out the
world
but as a way of justifying our positions
to each other
in a social uh context so that i am
the re i reason because this provides me
with a way to uh
wait wait to justify why it is that i
deserve all of the tomato sauce
whereas you um sort of basically deserve
nothing and
you then come back at me with a set of
vigorous counter arguments as to why it
is that you deserve all the nato sauce
and uh
we then bicker in a way that i'm all too
familiar with from being the
parent of two uh children uh
but that is that is a lot of how human
society works and so but then
i think the interesting thing that mercy
and sperver do is they say well
this these these uh blindnesses that we
have you know
that reason is basically a means of
justifying self-interest go together as
a set of cognitive
mechanisms so that we're really good at
understanding
and seeing the holes in other people's
[ __ ] even if we are not good at
seeing the holes in our own
and therefore if you can construct
appropriate
group scenarios and if there's at least
a minimal degree of
willingness on our part to self-correct
we can then begin to actually use these
groups you know so to have
you criticizing and telling me why my
arguments suck and vice versa
and then we can converge upon something
that actually helps us to solve this
bigger problem of how to distribute the
tomato sauce uh
in a way that actually uh works for
everybody
and so there's a lot of work that
cognitive psychologists have done
trying to figure out what are the
circumstances under which you are able
to do this
under which group processes work in
order to discover
and this is something that democracy
clearly can take advantage of and this
is getting back to the
point about the relationship to markets
that democracy can do
in a way that markets are probably
pretty poorly suited
to do because they are really about pure
buying and selling and the price
mechanism
and hierarchy also is pretty hard to do
because it is really hard for example
for you to offer good compelling reasons
for why you're a boss who can fire you
at a moment's notice
i shouldn't have all the tomato sauce
and hence a lot of that discussion
tends to get short-circuited by the
reality of power relations
when it comes to hiring finding good
people is important but it's finding
great people that makes all the
difference
and indeed is the job site that makes
that possible you can post
screen and interview your candidates all
on indeed
indeed makes connecting with and hiring
the right talent fast and easy with
tools like
indeed instant match which gives you
quality candidates whose resumes
fit your job description immediately and
indeed skills tests that on average
reduces hiring time by 27 percent on
indeed you'll find a quality short list
of candidates faster
and you will only pay for candidates
that meet your
must have qualifications then you can
schedule and complete video interviews
right there in the indeed dashboard
according to talentnest
indeed delivers four times more hires
than all other job sites combined
so get started right now with a free 75
dollar sponsored job credit
to upgrade your job post at indeed.com
mindscape that's a 75 credit at
indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through june 30th
terms and conditions apply
is it i'm sure it is an
oversimplification how much of an
oversimplification is it
to cast that argument against
markets as good decision makers or
compared to democracy anyway
simply as the fact that the price is too
little information right
i mean it's a it's a very the price of a
good is a very
nice quantitative thing that is set by
some equilibrium condition that we all
understand but it's only one number
right and and maybe
the point is that there's a whole bunch
of other numbers and more subtleties
that actual real conversation between
people
can involve in a way that simply setting
a price cannot
that's absolutely right and this is
something that joe stiglitz who's a
nobel prize winning economist his
uh his uh economics of information makes
this point
at great lengths that the price signal
it does wonderful things
but that you simply cannot expect the
price signal to bear sufficient
information
to produce many of the nice results that
economists would like uh it to produce
in terms of having
markets work well so in a sense what you
can see you know i think that the
intellectual trick that hayek uh did
there and
what he's doing he's arguing against
he's arguing against uh people who argue
that who claim that state planning
can effectively serve as a substitute
for markets
and so he may he takes a somewhat
extreme position which is that
he suggests that really the knowledge
that is most important to us
is precisely the knowledge that is tacit
the knowledge that cannot be
uh that cannot be readily uh readily uh
verbally communicated
that cannot be systematized and uh this
allows him
uh to make a very very strong case
against
uh state socialists and others who want
state planning as an alternative to
markets
and in many ways obviously a correct
argument it turns out that those systems
work terribly badly
but it also means that he more or less
systematically precludes the possibility
that people through discussing and
through arguing and
through talking with each other can
often uh actually
uh can often actually solve problems in
ways that cannot be reduced to the price
mechanism
and the final point which is i think an
interesting point is that very often
markets can be a place where this goes
on so this is one of the arguments that
john stuart mill makes back in the 19th
century
and where he says that the reason why
markets are so beneficial to us
isn't necessarily because of the buying
and the selling but because when you
have world markets
people are suddenly introduced to a wide
variety of different ways of knowing
of different societies of different
approaches to problems
and he sees this as being the important
dynamic benefit of markets
and obviously this is not hayekian
benefit and equally
the more that markets approach spot
market
type relationships in which there is
much less communication
much less banter and much more i'm sort
of somebody anonymous on ebay
buying or selling something else
anonymous on ebay
the more that we approach towards that
the uh less that markets are capable of
carrying
these other signals in the price signal
which help us to coordinate and help us
to learn
so to make it very very practical i mean
it was the kind of scenarios
that we're contrasting here uh a truly
hayekian one
which is uh very laissez-faire
capitalist and everyone is just buying
and selling according to their
individual self-interests and he
tries to make an argument that in fact
this is optimizing
various good things but the
counter-argument is that
there's more that we should be taking
into consideration
and a democracy would allow us to for
example just be very down to earth about
it
put regulations on what a corporation
can do which the market would
not necessarily do but the society
decides that's a better solution to its
collective problems
that's right and i think now in fairness
to hayek he does not
he's not an optimizer he is not one of
the people who argues that you can come
up with optimal solutions
instead he is trying to think in a
roughly evolutionary way
and he's making evolutionary arguments
for the benefits of markets
but he also and this is a point that i
think comes out really well in a book
that a historian quince labodian wrote
which came out about two or three years
ago
uh called the globalists hayek and his
followers uh
on the one hand they're committed to
this kind of
global constitution you might say of wto
type rules as a kind of straight jacket
on the ability of states
whether they're democratic or
non-democratic to do stuff that might
for example
involve a heavy regulations that might
that might limit property rights and
whatever
but also high ex disciples are very very
strongly opposed to the gathering
of useful knowledge statistical
knowledge
and all of these other forms of
knowledge which they see as being
a kind of perversion which might give
our policy makers the false belief
that they can actually impose these
regulations and impose these rules and
have anything go on and that and
i think that there are some other very
interesting twists yes one question that
i think is a huge
question that we need to think about is
what happens when
economic activities become sufficiently
complex
that it is impossible for regulators to
keep up with them you can think about
this for example
with regard to financial regulation you
know it's a huge problem the financial
regulators face
is that there's an incredible asymmetry
of comprehension that
uh it is really hard to understand what
many of the more complex
financial products are actually doing
what the market arrangements are
and so then this poses a very very
considerable problem for our on you know
for how democracy
or how democratic decision making works
what do we do
when it is impossible to it is
impossible effectively even for expert
policy makers
to actually effectively regulate a given
field of activity
and a whole bunch of other questions
spraying from that which are probably
too far afield
for us to discuss in a uh time limit
there is a time limit yeah
but i mean maybe this is the time just
take a little bit of an aside and talk
about the word neoliberalism because you
haven't quite said it but you've been
thinking about it
as you've been speaking i'm guessing but
and i think that this word is used a lot
and no one agrees on what it means and
specifically uh there are people who
think that neoliberalism is the worst
thing in the world and they have a
definition for it and people who think
is the best thing in the world and they
have a definition for it and they're
almost non-overlapping so
do you think this is a useful term and
how do you define it
um it's not a term that i use very often
myself
but it is a term put it this way there
are many people who use the term
neoliberalism and i would include quince
labodian who i just mentioned
among these people who use it in a
specific and precise way
of course their specific and precise
definition will disagree with somebody
else's specific and precise definition
so
that creates some confusion but
nonetheless i think you know
i think that it can be useful i i for me
i prefer to look at
smaller segments of the bigger problem
you know so too
you know that's just where i think my
skills lie i'm not somebody who is a
grand
social or economic thinker i'm more of a
tinkerer in some ways than a thinker i
think that uh
what i'd like to do is to try and pull
together collaborators or people from
other disciplines
and learn from them and to try to jam
ideas together to see what happens
uh but when it comes to sorry that's
that's a bit of an aside
when it comes to neoliberalism i think
slobodian so slobodian's definition of
it
is as i say that he thinks about this as
being this almost global institutional
straight jackets
that we have all of these people who
burrowed into these institutions
such as the gas the uh the uh originator
and progenitor of the world's trade
organization
into the international chamber of
commerce back in the 1930s 1940s 1950s
and managed to create these global rules
such as rules on investment
which then constrained the things and
the things that both democratic
and non-democratic countries can do
so he thinks about it as being a market
backed up by a constitution and so here
again he's building on hayek and payet
has a lot of arguments about
constitution
and the way the constitutions help to
provide liberty
as against that you get many neoliberals
who think about
are not many neoliberals many critics of
neoliberalism who think about this as
being pure markets running rampant that
these are
that this is not about global rules this
is instead
about markets and the ways in which
markets are
effectively replacing our uh more
traditional ways of
getting on with each other and a lot of
these people
uh a lot of these people are followers
of uh polanyi of
carl pollani who's a great thinker of
the uh
of the early 20th century and who
coincidentally is the brother of michael
palani
who's a guy who gives hayek all of his
ideas about tacit and
diffuse knowledge so there's a a very
complex
intellectual set of debates happening
there so i think that
though each of these definitions of of
neoliberalism
can be useful uh but i guess
uh you know i guess i don't like to talk
about neoliberalism as such
precisely because it has these many
definitions
although i do think that you can learn
from people who define it in a
reasonably precise way
okay very good that's a that's a very
messy answer no i think it's a
necessarily messy answer because people
do use it in slightly different ways but
but it was an aside
let me let me get back to uh
can i draw a connection between what
what you were previously saying about
markets versus democracy where you know
democracy has in some sense
a richer informational content in what
it was allowed to use
to make decisions versus what we were
saying before about evolution and
natural selection because you said that
uh hayek sort of uses evolution
as a metaphor and maybe that's right i
mean maybe evolution really is like
the free market but evolution is really
just a bunch of individuals
uh with their own self-interest in mind
the interacting with their nearest
neighbors and
sort of giving up on this other thing
that human beings can do which is to
think more broadly and and sort of
conceptualize
collectively in a way that evolution
doesn't allow individual
organisms to take advantage of well i
think there are two things here first of
all
i think that one of the arguments that
charles lindbloo makes about markets i
think is a
it's a very astute one which is to say
that markets in a sense they
remove problems from the sphere of
political argument so that uh rather
than
arg and this is a different take in the
hayekian thing rather than
arguing or fighting over whether or not
i should have this amount of tomatoes
and you should have this amount of
tomatoes
it depends on what amount i can buy of
tomatoes and of course there is a lot of
inequality baked
into that but also there is a sense that
there is a solved political problem
that you have you have turned this
political problem of distribution
into one in which we are agreeing to
disagree but within a market system in
which
which
effectively serves as the means of
allocation of these things but the
second the more fundamental point that i
think you're making here
is really i think a herbert simon kind
of argument because simon
who i mentioned at the beginning of this
is i think somebody who
he is he is an economist he is a uh god
knows what he is he
he is one of these people whose uh
insights travel across half
a dozen different fields but what he
thinks about is he thinks about
markets and democratic institutions and
bureaucracies
as being structures of uh information
in a sense and of collective information
this is i think the key
difference between simon's understanding
of the economy
and say a um say your standard and sort
of econ 101 textbook understanding which
is
if you look at econ 101 if you look at
the ways in which they think about
individuals if you look at game theory
all of these they argue in effect that
uh
individuals have pretty well unlimited
ability to understand the environment
that they are
in and to figure out what is the optimal
strategy given that
environment obviously in game theory you
know so if you could have um sort of
complications there may be a game of
imperfect information in which
you do not know which particular branch
of the game tree you are on
but nonetheless you have you know you
and all of the other actors have common
knowledge regarding the
overall structure and the strategies
that are possible and all of these
things
and simon's argument is in fact human
beings are not like that human beings
are our ability to process information
is extremely limited
and so what this means is that in in
reality we tend to
toss out a lot of our information
processing
tasks to broader structures and those
can be markets
those can be political institutions
those can be democracies those can be
bureaucracies
there are a wide variety of different
things that we can do
here but the crucial point then is that
we have to pay attention to these
collective modes of problem solving
and in a sense if we think about markets
from a simon perspective
we'd have to think about markets too as
being a mode of collective problem
solving
rather than a mere aggregate of the uh
individually self-centered and uh fully
rational and fully
you know fully understood actions of uh
different people you know sort of coming
together to form this market
we have to look at how the market in a
sense becomes a set of institutions
that have ineluctably collective
properties and if we don't understand
that we're not going to be able to to
understand how actual
real-life markets actually work it's
emergence yeah i like it as a
i need to read herbert simon i've
actually never read anything by him so
that i
keep hearing people talk about him and
so i'm going to have to follow that up
but
the other thing but i also want to give
due to the idea of hierarchies because
you've contrasted in the paper uh
markets and democracies and hierarchies
and i think that you
there's some aside in which you say
there's actually not a lot of literature
trying to justify
hierarchical decision making as much
maybe because
in certain cases it's just obviously
true like in a business the boss is
going to decide
but in other cases like in a democracy
we think it's obviously
or we pretend anyway it's obviously
false that the decision should
bubble up from the bottom but so what is
the principled case for
a hierarchical decision making as the
right way to do this sort of social
optimization
problem we're thinking of well
hierarchies can get [ __ ] done
is i think one way of thinking about it
you know that that if you
are you know if if if you if you want to
get
big complex problems solved
at some stage or another you probably
want to have some degree of hierarchy in
there you want to have some decision
which is taken
some means of con of communicating that
decision
to a wide variety of actors who are the
people who are concerned with
implementing the solution
and some means to make sure that they
are actually implementing the solution
in ways that reflect the grand design
albeit was necessary fudging around the
edges in order to deal with unexpected
local conditions
and that their uh their way of solving
this that this all
adds up that they are not uh under
cutting each other
in some way or another so this is i
think the standard notion of
a hierarchy is that it is a way of
compartmentalizing
and organizing and understanding the
world and as
of then once you have a problem of
delivering solutions to it
so i think that the the uh one of the
classic works on hierarchy which we
don't talk about in this book
is seeing like a state which is by james
scott which is a wonderful
beautifully written book which i can't
say about many other political science
books
we are not known for our writing style
as a discipline but scott writes
beautifully
and so he argues you know uh more or
less what he's doing he's looking at
what he calls high modernism which is
this
set of hierarchical institutions which
come
into being in the you know really come
into play in the 18th and 19th century
and a lot of what they're trying to do
is to make the world legible
that is that if you are for example a
houseman
trying to redesign paris which is this
uh this
incredibly complex maze of uh rookeries
and
all sorts of uh unpleasant places with
some pleasant people doing unpleasant
things from your perspective
you start to build these grand
boulevards and some sort of this
very very straightforward layout and
you're doing this in order to make the
people of
paris visible to the state so that they
can be organized so that they can be
schools so that the uh
problems of riots and of crime have
become less apparent less less
less less deep than they were because it
is hard for people just to disappear
into this complex morass
where the state can't follow them and so
scott's argument is that this involves a
huge
losses of information that there is a
lot of tacit knowledge and here
uh he is in some ways semi-hayekian but
you can also look at this from the
point of view of you know there are a
lot of things that that hierarchy
is capable of doing that you really want
to do and you can think about this in
the united states at the moment
with respect to coronavirus that uh
there's one thing that we desperately
want above
all else which is a effective means for
uh distributing
the vaccines that we have as efficiently
as possible in ways that
minimize the minimize the impact of the
disease
and we are learning that one of the uh
you know over the last 20 30 40 years
that a lot of the state
instrumentalities which you might have
expected to be able to do this
have withered away and have disappeared
and so this is one of those
circumstances where hierarchy comes to
the fore so the
the hit against hierarchy is that it is
uh it is not particularly flexible
it is top down it tends also according
to scott to re-segment the world in ways
that
make it that fit its own concept that
fit its own ways of categorizing the
world and this
involves the loss of information the
benefits are
sewage uh you're dealing with diseases
all of these uh provisions of crucial
services which we couldn't live without
and which we need some kind of central
organized way of doing
in order to get that stuff done and i
have a whole other spiel i can give you
uh basically work with marion for cad
about how machine learning has a lot
more in common with uh scotian versions
of hierarchy
than it does with uh many of the uh you
know
with the market notions that people very
often apply but that's a red herring
which you can uh
you can you you can follow or leave to
inside no no i want to hear it i want to
hear about the relationship between
machine learning and a hierarchy but i
mean just to sum it up
the the good thing about hierarchy like
you said since
decision making is concentrated uh the
decisions get made quicker and things
get done
uh but they might not be the right
decisions because there's sort of less
wisdom being collectively integrated in
there
and if there's some relationship there
to machine learning i definitely want to
hear more about it
okay so i think that the argument that
this uh again as i say i
try to work with uh co-authors who are
brighter than me and marion
uh very definitely uh you know she she
this is this is applied versions of her
ideas uh without a huge amount of
originality on my part
but more or less we have this notion
that we call high-tech modernism and the
idea behind it
is that if you think about how machine
learning works it really it's a process
it's a process of categorization process
of classification use when you know
whether it's
supervised or you know primarily
supervised but also unsupervised machine
learning
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to take a data set and you're
trying to sort it out into
some kind of a classification scheme
which can then
allow you to figure out stuff to
identify relationships that you might
not have done
otherwise and so if you think about it
from that perspective
you immediately see that there is a
there is a very very strong
analogy to bureaucracy because that is
exactly what traditional bureaucracies
have done
traditional bureaucracies have always
looked to
classify and to figure out if you are
a uh i don't know a deviant irishman
or a upstanding uh loyal british citizen
or what have you
and uh they have done this uh messily
and efficiently and whatever was paper
files
but there's something pretty strongly
the case you know so that you know
there's something very very similar and
the way many of the
fights that we see happening around
machine learning and about machine
learning and equity machine learning and
racial bias are in many ways they're new
versions of the fights that we have been
having
since forever about the way for example
in which redlining was used by
uh financial institutions to uh
effectively uh
you know make it impossible for people
in entire neighborhoods to
uh get loans so uh so we see not the
same debate because of course as the
technologies change
things you know things about uh things
change
change about how the technologies are
applied and their social impact
but there's a strong relationship there
the key difference i think
with machine learning to the kinds of
stuff that james scott was talking about
is that when you think about james scott
and the way that he talks about these
cities being created
to uh map uh map the bureaucratic
categories onto the world around them
the process with machine learning it's
much more subtle yes we are all carrying
around with us these uh little
devices in our pockets which are
endlessly feeding information to the
mother ship
allowing the mother mothership to
classify us and categorize us in
different ways
cookies whatever new thing google is
coming up with to replace cookies
all of these are intended to uh
categorize and
classify us and they have these very
substantial consequences uh they guide
you into being the kind of person
who gets a sweet mortgage offers versus
the kind of person who gets the uh
kinds of um sort of predatory loans that
we see advertised on the side of subway
cars
but the uh these processes of guiding
tend to be much more invisible
than the more direct forms of repression
that we've seen in previous eras
and so then the question that gets back
to what you're saying
about the ways in which hierarchy can go
wrong the question is what kinds of
feedback loops are there
through which you can correct some of
these uh problems so if you think about
a hierarchy you know say for example if
you think about authoritarian regimes
authoritarian regimes are notoriously
terrible at
taking feedback as they try to monitor
what their citizens are doing and
thinking because they want to stay in
power
but when the feedback tells them things
that they don't really want to know it's
very hard to penetrate through the
system
and one of the interesting questions
with machine learning is if you have
these feedback loops which are
largely automated and which provide very
little room for
actual people to insert themselves into
the process and say hey
this isn't actually what we want uh
how do you change that how do you get
into a world
in which machine learning is
democratized and that's a huge problem
well this is good because i think it
leads us in even if i buy which i do
the idea that democracy is a good way of
making decisions
in comparison uh on a fair level playing
ground with
markets or hierarchies democracy has its
issues right and you know when we uh
go from the ideal theory to the real
world
we have a whole bunch of people as the
critics would would let you know that
are not very well informed or they have
incoherent
uh beliefs themselves right so it's not
even just a majority vote would get you
as a simple decision-making process
and increasingly they're in people in
the world
are of the opinion that the real power
is too far away from them right even if
they live in a democracy
it's a representative democracy it's a
republic right as we're told not a
democracy
uh and they don't see this direct
influence of their voice on the
decisions
being made so is the modern world making
it harder for democracies to function in
this ideal way
yes well this is one of the arguments i
think people like piketty have made
at length which is that as you see
wealth inequality going up
this begins to feed into the political
process in some important ways so you
see
political scientists like uh chris aiken
and larry bartels
you see uh also paul pearson and jacob
hacker who are uh
you know who have written books that try
to describe this
uh in a broader public arena so you see
these feedback loops developing
between wealth and political power so
that many of the forms of democratic
representation
which are supposed to work in order to
give people some power
really don't work anymore you also see i
think
other more subtle forms of
differentiation which i think are more
uncomfortable for people on the liberal
left
deal with which is that the lives that
you and i live as a
college professors who have pretty
comfortable sweet deals
are more and more divergent from the
lives of a lot of people
who don't see very much in the way of
economic opportunities
and uh there is a degree of invisibility
there uh and you know
that you know that that i think we have
begun to realize that
there are many many problems that have
been simmering
away beneath the surface of american
democracy that we got entirely
too comfortable with and that we uh we
we don't we we we we we ha
we simply haven't confronted and i think
in some ways still are not confronting
because they are too difficult for us to
confront
and i think the final question is that
to what extent
democracy itself is a stable system
and so here and again this is yet
another coarser i
think in terms of co-authors uh i think
try to think
in terms of my work with causers another
quarter of mine is bruce schneier who is
a
uh computer scientist and a
cryptographer a cryptographer
and so we have been thinking together
about what is democracy as a dynamic
system
and what kinds of feedback loops uh
democracy needs to work
and what kinds of feedback loops can go
uh go astray
and roughly our argument is that many of
the things that have gone bad
over the last number of years are
feedback loops which under other
circumstances could be reinforcing for
democracy that is
if we think for example about um about
politicians ambitions yes if you want
politicians to be selfishly ambitious
to want to win power and whatever in the
democratic system
but you want them to do this by
appealing to voters so that is when
democracy works it's when politicians
are vying with each other
to try to appeal to voters and try to
figure out ways to
attract voters to them and of course
when that ambition begins to get
disconnected so that they begin to
refuse election results that becomes
much more problematic
you see similar things with uh distrust
in election systems
i you probably do want to have citizens
not uh
not not being entirely trusting of
election officials are of election
systems because things can indeed go
very badly wrong
again that is a kind of suspicion
which has uh metastasized in some
importantly problematic ways and finally
you want democracy to be a relatively
open system to new ideas this is where
it gets its benefits
it's from the fact that new groups can
articulate their interests and organize
and we can think about good ways in
which that has happened such as black
lives matters
we can also think of and that is
something that probably would not have
been possible in the more closed off
democratic system
of the 1950s but we also can think about
a negative aspect such as q anon
and the various forms of conspiratorial
communities which have formed on the
internet
and so then this doesn't necessarily
help us to solve the problem
but uh it helps us to see how it is that
some of the feedback loops that under
other circumstances
can reinforce democracy uh are
tearing american democracy uh apart to
some degree
and to start to try to think more
systematically about how to redirect
those
uh redirect those uh feedback loops in
ways that are more positive and more
beneficial
because it's hard to argue a uh
unqualified case in particular for u.s
democracy at the moment because u.s
democracy sucks there are a
huge huge problem well you know i
recently talked
on the podcast with zainab toufetchi uh
and i think
she she said something important that i
think she gave credit to herbert simon
for uh
saying about the importance not of
necessarily of information but of
attention
in the modern world because we've sort
of crossed some threshold where there's
just too much information out there
and now the question is what do you pay
attention to and
so one way that bad actors
can uh combat or you know try to get
their point across is just to flood the
zone
with with [ __ ] right and yeah that
that does seem to raise a new kind of
challenge for democracy i mean people
were lying and misleading all the time
but just the volume of it that we can
get and now we're we're able to
uh immerse ourselves in in
pools of false falsehoods in ways that
we couldn't before
is there is there a mechanism internal
to democracy that will help us get out
of that kind of dilemma
well the ways that you know my version
of xenapp's argument the quip
you may you may have heard a saying
among many first amendment people
that the best solution to uh bad speech
is more speech
and so uh i think what authoritarian
rulers discovered number of years ago is
that the
best solution to more speech is bad
speech that is that if you
if you flood the zone with [ __ ] it
becomes incredibly difficult for people
to figure out what is happening anymore
and if you are you know if you're the
rulers and if you're able to prevent
people from in the opposition from
communicating with each other
from organizing from knowing what the
reality of
politics is what people actually want
them to do and so on
then you are already starting with a
substantial advantage so
i think one of the key research
questions that we have to figure out at
the moment
is how we can try to mitigate and this
is something
bruce and i wrote a paper making these
arguments about the
vulnerabilities of democracies to
information flow flooding
more or less arguing that we had you
know we know a lot about how autocracies
are vulnerable to certain kinds of
information flows
we need to start thinking about how
democracies too
have these kinds of vulnerabilities i
think where we need to start
experimenting is trying to figure out
how best to mitigate because we do not
want to move into a world which is a
world of strong gatekeepers again
because that world is a world in which
much of the benefit of democracy
disappears
but we want to figure out ways in which
we can at least tamp down
disinformation flows and some of this
will of course involve as everybody says
working with uh social media and
figuring out the ways in which
both algorithms and self-selection by
people who are looking for crazy stuff
at the
start how those things work and how to
minimize and
to mitigate their negative consequences
while preserving
benefits uh the benefits of free
organizations they provide
some of it also will involve us thinking
in a different sense about
media regulation of traditional media
and i think this is a work
that in particular we see coming from
people associated with the uh berkman
klein
uh center at harvard there has been a
lot of work which suggested if you
really want to see where the
bad stuff happened in uh recent
elections it happened
via fox news so that there is
effectively
a conveyor belt that you see where
where um where both the left and the
right
have a lot of nonsense floating around
the fringes you know so that is just a
necessary fact
of uh how it is the people are but that
on the
conservative side of the spectrum we saw
a lot of this nonsense being
effectively hoovered up by fox news
through a variety of means
and then injected into the mainstream of
public debate
so i think you know if we want to think
about reform of media
i think that going after platform
companies is one good
and important thing but figuring out
ways that we can
force more uh traditional media to also
be more responsible
while preserving their ability to
exercise independent voice
is something that we need to think about
very carefully as well
one of the few moments of hope in the
last couple of months of misery
has been seeing fox news suddenly begin
to realize
that it can't make these crazy
statements about
election machine manufacturers without
having some legal liability
so uh one of the things that bruce and i
have toyed around with a little bit
is the possibility of whether or not you
know are there ways in which that can be
built upon to try and create some kind
of
a moderating mechanism towards uh making
uh
it more in the incentivizing these
places to uh tell the truth
even if they still provide a slanted
version of the truth a slanted version
of the truth which is not entirely
disconnected from reality
yeah no and maybe you could even
elaborate on that a little bit because i
think this is like the
really crucial question uh we want there
to be a diversity of opinions and voices
and values out there in the media but
we should also be able to say we would
like the factual information to be true
as much as it can be and right now the
incentive structure is not necessarily
aligned in that way and
you brought up the example of the voting
machine companies and so
here you had some big companies that had
the both the huts button the resources
to bring lawsuits
say don't lie about us and that seemed
to work how scalable is that mechanism
to stop uh major media corporations from
just spreading false facts out there
into the world
not particularly but i you know one one
idea and yo so this is
i am not a policy person and uh bruce is
in different ways but this is not his
area of policy
but one thing that you know one way that
you might be able to think about doing
this
is by obliging as a licensing
requirement
tv stations to have a and other
broadcasters have a significant
fact-checking uh truth-checking uh
apparatus as part of their uh as part of
their makeup
and the idea behind this is as follows
that then this be makes it
far harder for them to argue in court
that they
uh you know so that that other they have
not been committing
malicious slander or libel if they have
a place you know if they have
parts of their apparatus which are
specific specifically
devoted to figuring out the stuff uh it
it it could be taken to imply
a greater level of uh you know of
assumed responsibility for them
actually getting stuff right whether
that actually works or not depends upon
a lot of specific and detailed
regulatory knowledge and legal knowledge
that uh i don't have and that uh bruce
you know this is not bruce's
specific area either but those are the
kinds of things that i think that you
know the kinds of places that i would
start to look in
i would also uh look to the uh you know
to the act that uh
the democrats are trying to get through
uh which is trying to minimize uh
your various forms of gerrymandering
among other uh other forms of abuses of
the electoral system
and uh finally i think that there is a
lot of argument to be made for
uh different voting approaches to voting
so transferable voting of one sort or
another
uh lee drotman has a book where he
recently makes this argument you can
think about this also in terms of
uh benefits for information because one
of the problems we have at the moment
is that on the right side of the
spectrum the extreme
crazies uh uh in the republican party
and the uh more moderate people are are
bundled in together
and it becomes a shibboleth that you
more or less have to subscribe to
certain kinds of beliefs or else not be
considered to be a republican
in good standing if you had a uh
a different voting system which might
make it easier for different
parties on the right to emerge then
it would become that might help you to
help help provide people who don't
subscribe to the uh
full donald trump i was uh
illegitimately denied the election
uh mantra to uh form their own party
and i hence my hence might make it
easier
uh you know also to to isolate the crazy
people
and the crazy beliefs from those who uh
probably don't believe all
are much of the uh much of the stuff but
who feel that they have to go along with
it because
of pressures towards social conformity
let me uh sort of start winding things
up with getting one more big idea on the
table here because we've talked a lot
about
using democracy putting it to work uh to
make decisions and i think it's a
it's a persuasive case that you know a
diversity of voices connected in a in a
very
functional way is a good way of solving
complicated problems
but then there's the flip side of that
which is the evolution of democracies
themselves
something that you've also written about
the the the literal evolution right
the uh the evolution over time and maybe
maybe there's a
biological metaphor lurking there too uh
but you talk about the examples of
athens and sparta as as two different
uh ways uh that that purported
democracies can evolve and i i was
amused to read in your paper that these
are two of the best studied
political systems in history they were
they were quite a long time ago but
why don't you tell us the story very
quickly of uh athens and sparta and what
they teach us about the evolution of
these institutions
so what they are they're so they're
they're very well studied
and they're canonical cases for uh
better or for worse that is that a lot
of our ideas about politics
came through the romans who in turn were
profoundly indebted to the greeks for
their culture
for their understanding of how politics
worked so there's a lot of
past dependence in the examples and also
they have a
nice blend of on the one hand they have
enough factual information that you can
figure out a lot of what happened but
there also are enough open spaces that
you can
uh go so you know you you you can then
begin to play around and
uh and use them as examples uh you know
so that that help
that make it easier to connect uh that
then uh might be the case if you
you know if you had am sort of much more
detailed and boring set
of uh you know there's somebody some
historian once said that
fire and flood are a historian's two
best friends
and i think that there's a little bit of
that going on here as well
uh but nonetheless i think what they do
suggest they do provide uh you know all
joking aside they do provide
instances of two very different
trajectories and
if you think about sparta as being a
pretty
clear example of autocracy and of a very
strong form of autocracy where you have
a relatively small self-reproducing uh
ruling class you have a
uh you have a somewhat bigger class of
uh people who don't have citizenship
rights
but have some rights periodically
they're called and their values they're
around
the limits of the community of the
household and then you have a massive
population of serfs or slaves the
hellets
and spartan society is all organized in
the same way that the 19th century
south was all organized about keeping
the health down about keeping them uh
you know keeping them from getting power
uh keeping them from getting weapons
keeping them from getting organized
keeping them from getting delivered
so this is a very it's a and in some
ways you could say it's a successful
society
for very limited and unpleasant forms of
success
in that it manages to survive for
several centuries but it manages to
survive in an extremely static way they
they
don't they don't they they don't allow
the introduction of money they are
extremely suspicious of
innovations uh it is a it is a
particularly
unpleasant society even by the
uh standards of ancient societies and
even if you're a member of the elite
you probably have a pretty miserable
time in sparta
absence in contrast is at best a flawed
democracy
from our perspective it again is a slave
society there are a lot of people who
are enslaved and that is an important
basis of the economy slaves and the
silver mines as well as in a variety of
other
capacities uh there are women don't have
anything even vaguely approaching full
political rights
and there is a population of medics who
i don't have
citizen rights but do have certain other
rights as well so it's it's
it's not perfect by any stretch of the
imagination
but it's a hell of a lot better than
sparta and you see a lot of the benefits
and disadvantages of democracy you know
this dynamic ability to
to adapt to uh to bring in innovations
from
other countries when those innovations
look to be useful are helpful
innovations
it's a place which is affirmative and
the reason of course why we remember
athens is because uh during that period
of when uh socrates plato uh
euripides aristophanes in a very
different way
you know these are people whose work i'm
sort of uh flowered and
um and and there's a sense of a common
culture there
which fertilizes which explodes and
which really i'm sort of even apart from
the kind of the
post-hoc ways in which we think of this
as being awesome i think you can
reasonably say that
it is uh objectively there is a lot of
wonderful cultural material which is
produced and this is
not divorced from the political and
economic
context that's that athens was in it has
a lot of uh
other problems it's an imperial power
and uh and a lot of its wealth is
developed frankly by
exploitation of other uh greek states
but
again it it it provides a way to see how
it is that you can get a dynamic society
where the power relations are much more
moderate than they are in sparta
even if they are pretty extreme by
modern circumstances
and uh and and hence this is why we use
these examples as
our ways of thinking through this and
did they teach us something about the
relative
uh merits of stability versus dynamism i
mean you want both a little bit right
you want to be a little bit stable
otherwise you're in trouble
but you also want to be able to adapt
the change and getting that balance
right is always a tricky thing it's
always a very tricky thing and i think
that the strengths
of any political system and this is a
huge huge problem this gets back to the
beginning of our argument for political
scientists
political scientists by and large don't
tend to think in dynamical terms
and to the extent that we do think in
dynamical terms we often find ourselves
in sort of drifting back
without even realizing it back into a
static
frameworks and configuration so there is
this approach in political science
called historical institutionalism
which is all supposed to be about use of
processes of institutional change over
time
but as kathy thalin who's one of the
chief progenitors of this approach
has complained very often people who are
historical institutions
they say they're about change but really
when you look at it it's all about the
same old same old same old
that they managed to get pulled back
into it so uh if the strengths of
any of these systems are dynamical this
means a number of things first of all it
means that we cannot
we can come up with accounts of the
dynamical advantages of one
thing over another across a large
spectrum of possible parameters uh but
we also you know so
we do you know so if we have to preserve
in the back of our heads
the possibility that you know so even if
we think that one particular system
is better overall that there may be
specific shock specific problems that it
is going to encounter
which is going to do worse in dealing
with than other systems
might uh we have to you know we have to
think about
how institutions work in different ways
we have to think about them as flows
and it's hard to come up with really
really hard and fast you know
this is universally better than that
observe across all possible states of
the world
but uh i think it's still possible to
come up with a reasonable
across most reasonable circumstances
kinds of generalizations
where you can and and generalizations
that even if they are more limited
than one would have in a more static
account of the world
generalizations that probably are at
least a little bit more true to reality
in that we know that we live in this
dynamic chaotical world and we
need to understand better how these
systems work and i'd uh
two other people who i recommend here
scott page and jenna bedner
both of whom have done uh wonderful work
in different ways
thinking about these problems of
institutional change and thinking in
particular about the uh
about the ways in which diversity plays
an important role in all this
well if it makes you feel any better uh
even within physics
uh the study of statistical mechanics
has historically almost
always been in the equilibrium context
and it's only in the last 15 or 20 years
that we've really been taking
non-equilibrium statistical mechanics
very seriously so
i wonder if there isn't room for
importing some of the fluctuation
theorems and studies of deviations from
equilibrium from physics
into these studies of of societies that
sounds like an ambitious thing but maybe
uh
worth looking into well there's gold and
then their health i would say for those
of your listeners who are interested
the one thing i would say is that there
is a uh there's a long-standing history
of uh physicists coming in and saying
okay
this is a here's our problem here is my
um sort of uh
you know icing or whatever though how do
you pronounce this name i've never
ising i think yeah yeah uh you know
here's my
work horse model i am going to show you
how my workhorse
horse model generates something that
kind of looks like what you're talking
about if you squint at it in the right
kind of way
and there is my publication and you
peons can then go and figure out how to
apply it
that's not going to work i i think that
if you want to generate
real understanding there is a huge
amount of
open space for you to do so but you
should do so through
engagement with social scientists who
are already working there
and through engagement with the actual
messiness of real life which is uh which
is of course what we're all trying to
capture here
and i cannot think of a better final
thought than that one so
henry farrell thanks very much for being
on the mindscape podcast
thank you so much
[Music]
you